one of the nineteen members of South
Africa's Truth and Reconciliation
Commission psychologists pool acabo de
madikizela weaves together stories from
apartheid victims and perpetrators in
her new book a human being died that
night this talk runs an hour and a half
for those of you who are new to facing
history and I do see a lot of familiar
faces and thank you for joining us once
again facing history very briefly is an
international nonprofit teacher training
professional development organization
and what we do is to train teachers to
help them challenge their students to
ask really deep questions to question
assumptions and to look at history in a
really deep way and this is why we have
people like Puma involve Puma and albie
sachs both our friends are facing
history and have come to work with us as
scholars and as people who have actually
lived that history whom allah has
written her book about a piece of that
history that she was involved in about
forgiveness and remorse and the question
of how do you do that after a period of
collective violence but I'll let her
talk more about that i want to tell you
just a little bit about Puma and a
little bit about Albie Sachs pula is an
associate professor okay I'm sorry puma
is an associate professor at Cape Town
University an adjunct professor of
Unilever ethics center faculty affiliate
at the coexistence program at Brandeis
ethics center she's a recipient of
numerous awards from Harvard UCLA
University of Michigan taught psychology
at the University of Trance keys and
more importantly to the book that she's
speaking to tonight hula served on the
truth and reconciliation commission from
99 to 2001 she taught at Brandeis tubs
and Wellesley and worked was facing
history doing workshops for teachers
while she was there she has lectured
extensively on the issues of forgiveness
apology and remorse justice Albie Sachs
is another remarkable figure in the
history of South Africa
a member of the South African
Constitutional Court he began as a civil
rights lawyer in the 50s and 60s and has
been a leader in the struggle for Human
Rights there as a freedom fighter for
the African National Congress and was
actually nearly killed by a car bomb in
88 for his work in that area justice
Sachs has written extensively on Human
Rights culture gender and the
environment we are very honored that
he's joining formula here today tonight
thank you so much and now I'd like to
just welcome home la kavod Amanda cos
Ayla thank you good evening everyone and
thanks very much Laurie I it's
appropriate I think that I should
acknowledge the privilege and real great
honor to have a be with me tonight when
I heard that I was going to be touring
the states with my book he said to me oh
I'm going to be in the states at the
same time tell me where you're going and
then I can come and join you I was
ecstatic as you can imagine and as it
happened he was going to be in trivalent
on the same day that I'm here as you can
see so it's a really wonderful privilege
and thank you very very much avi in that
you took time to be with us this evening
to be with me this evening thank you and
thank you all and a very good evening
ten years ago the South African interim
constitution was agreed upon at the
multi-party negotiations that led to the
first multi-racial elections in south
africa in april of nineteen ninety-four
an addendum to the interim constitution
provided for the establishment of the
Truth and Reconciliation Commission the
goals of the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission were stated very clearly
in this post amber primary among these
where firstly it needs to quote
transcend the divisions and strife of
the past and quote by confronting the
truth secondly a needs to advance
reconciliation and to transcend hate and
vengeance so it was very clear that the
language of justice had been redefined
to make the work of the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission possible the
post amble also provided for the
granting of amnesty for serious offenses
associated with political objectives or
crimes committed in the context of past
political conflict there was heated
debate about the granting of amnesty for
perpetrators of atrocities in South
Africa people from different sides of
the political conflict had different
views about how this amnesty were to be
meted out FWD Clegg the last president
of a part 8 of the apartheid government
wanted a blanket amnesty for all members
of the police force and the army but
then the members of the ANC the leaders
within the ANC said no way that would be
amnesia we cannot move forward in this
country if we want a healthy society
social cohesion and peaceful society we
had to we have to go back and get these
people to testify publicly about the
crimes they committed in the past they
cannot be granted blanket amnesty
subsequently an Act of Parliament the
National healing and reconciliation ads
was promulgated it was passed by an act
of parliament and in 1995 and so the
truth and reconciliation commission was
established in December of the day in
1995 with Nobel Peace Laureate especial
Desmond Tutu as its chairman one of the
most important functions
served by the TRC the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission was its truth
recovery process now what does this
truth recovery process the biggest
importance about this process of
truth-telling on the truth commission is
that it was not truth from one side only
it was truth from all sides it was truth
actually that brought together all the
voices that were involved in the
political countries as we all know all
societies that have suffered trauma have
got certain things in common including
victims perpetrators and bystanders now
The Truth and Reconciliation Commission
brought all these voices the voices of
victims of perpetrators in the voices of
bystanders on the public stage of the
Truth and Reconciliation Commission now
for victims the importance of
truth-telling mainly is acknowledgement
the acknowledgement of their pain many
people who came to the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission to give
testimony had suffered tragic tragic
effects of the trauma of the past they
were traumatized it is many of you know
those of you work with trauma we will
remember you will remember that victims
of trauma needs to have their pain
acknowledged for any victim of trauma
one of the most important things that
victims need is acknowledgement of their
trauma in order to heal their pain now
similarly in a country data suffered
trauma there is nothing is important as
acknowledgement of pain now many people
believe that to revisit pain is to open
up one's yes it does open up up ones but
there is no way that victims can heal
unless they go back to take that path to
walk that journey towards healing it is
important for the pain of the teams to
be acknowledged particularly but though
by those who have caused their pain the
reason for this is simple it is that
when victim suffered a trauma it is an
overwhelming moment that is beyond their
control
when victims are exposed to traumatic
episodes they lose control of their
lives they lose control of themselves
they don't have a framework within which
to understand what is happening to them
in fact the goal of the traumatic
episode the goal of a perpetrator is
precisely to do that to take away the
victims control and there is nothing
that takes away one's identity one's
dignity has to be robbed of any sort of
control when drama happens victims don't
know how to deal with the moment because
in part because it is so overwhelming it
is not something that they are used in
or something against which they can
measure their experience when you and I
experience ordinary the ordinary mishaps
of every day we know how to handle it
you fall you get up you brush yourself
you start walking again when a traumatic
moment happens it takes away all of your
abilities to deal with it so there is
something of the victim that is lost
something of the victim's identity that
they lose when they suffer a traumatic
moment so they're telling the truth
telling that moment of truth telling is
important precisely because it gives
back to the victim that sense of control
when there is truth before the victim
there is a sense of understanding of how
this incident happened who was
responsible for it why they did it all
that idea of building truth about what
happened answering all those critical
questions that victims were not able to
answer gives them back a sense of power
sense of control over their lives a
sense of regaining their sense of
identity their sense of dignity that is
why that moment for victims of trauma
was so important in the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission in South
Africa many of these victims had no
recourse in the law they went to the
quad rooms but what they were told was
that no one was responsible for their
crimes there is nothing as it is
frustrating it is disempowering for the
then not to know that they're not to
have an identity of a person someone who
is responsible for the end so what the
Commission provided was to give them a
voice to break that silence that they
were forced to suffer for so many years
and put them in the center stage of the
entire society in South Africa the
entire world in fact victims were able
to be given the respect that that was
their moment to be standing up there and
to talk about their pain in the way that
they chose to there was no the facts
only madam has happened so often in crim
the criminal justice system here victims
talked about their pain in the way that
they remembered it in the way that they
wanted to talk about it and so it was
very crucial that was the most important
part of the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission now there are the
perpetrators also now perpetrators have
lost their sense of moral humanity the
reason that they were able to commit
their atrocities was not only because
they dehumanized their victims but they
do humanize themselves in order for
perpetrators to be able to commit their
terrible deeds they lose sense of or
they deny the sense of who they are as
moral human being meet beings they deny
that morality that that core of being a
human being that describes them as being
as part of of the the the moral human
humanity and so when the Commission gave
them the opportunity to speak in public
or when the Commission required them to
speak in public it forced them to face
their deeds forced them to face their
evil and by the so doing it enabled them
to go beyond their sense of guilt some
perpetrators were able to feel guilt
about their deals in the past and the
problem with guilt sometimes is that
often perpetrators are stuck at the
level of guilt and guilts usually comes
with denial because it is so heavy
people
want to admit responsibility they feel
guilty they may or may not admit
responsibility what the Commission did
was to force them to admit guilt and
many of them were able to go beyond the
guilt and to feel the sense or the need
to apologize to their victims and and to
even go beyond and to feel a sense of
remorse for what they did now that
process enables perpetrators to reclaim
their sense of moral humanity to reclaim
their sense of being part of this model
human world the part of themselves that
they had lost when they were committing
their atrocities the hearings allowed
them to reach out and to reach deeply
into their conscience and to hear that
voice of conscience for those who do who
do have a conscience and so that a
moment was important not only for
victims to regain their dignity and
respect but also for perpetrators to
regain their sense of moral humanity now
the amazing thing that happened in the
truth commission is that the encounter
between victim and perpetrator often led
to a relationship the building of a
relationship between victim and
perpetrator the apologists expressed by
perpetrators are particularly the
remorseful apologies invited victims to
reach out and back to perpetrators with
forgiveness and that was the greatest
achievement of the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission something
which we have not seen in the history of
atrocities in the 20th century the
expression of forgiveness in the context
of so much tragedy my book is a way of
understanding what happens in these
encounters a way of trying to understand
for myself personally what happened in
my own encounter with one of our parties
worse perpetrators the man who is
considered to be prime evil the person
who embodies all of the evil of
apartheid because he has been brandished
as the one who carries the burden of
apartheid regime decock now Eugene de
Kock was a party's the head of a party
is covert operations unit he headed up a
farm a units on a farm a secret farm
just outside the capital of South Africa
Pretoria and on this farm he trained hit
squads death squads young black men that
they had captured from coming back into
South Africa to conduct operations
within the country they would capture
them and they would torture them and
turn them to become collaborators with
the states and so they had a group of
this young man at this far it is on this
farm flat blast along with many many
such a white security policemen who were
trained to be assassins and in murder
squads they committed the most the most
tragic incidents in this in the history
of apartheid South Africa they were sent
out to plant bombs or they were taught
how to build bombs that would explode in
cars they were sent out to build a bombs
within pens and send gifts to their
targeted activists that would explode on
being opened pens letters all sorts of
radios all sorts of things that you and
I consider the common things that we use
on a day-to-day basis apartheid
redefined everything nothing was sacred
everything was it put was a potential
ammunition for them to commit their
terrible deeds so this farm was headed
by Eugene de Kock and he himself with
his own hands participated in many of
these meda operations he crossed the
border with his men to kill members of
the liberation movement people who were
in exile living in different temps in
the neighboring states of South Africa
and he went out with his men and did
conduct
operations himself Eugene de Kock was
arrested shortly after the first
democratic elections in south africa in
april nineteen ninety four years
arrested about may and he was a charged
with a series of crime of crimes and
eventually convicted and sentenced to
two hundred and twelve years in prison
and two life sentences for the crimes he
committed as head of this apart aids
covert operations unit because this was
a time where everyone approached the
truth commission to apply for amnesty
like many perpetrators from both sides
of the conflict black and white
perpetrators you gently cog applied to
the commission trying to get amnesty
after when after he had been sentenced
to do to these terms in prison and this
my journey with Eugene de Kock begins
with his first appearance on The Truth
and Reconciliation Commission de Kock on
his first when he testified for the
first time at the hearings of the
Commission requested to meet with widows
of thumb of his victims and to meet
privately with widows or some of his
victims in at that meeting he asked for
their forgiveness now I was intrigued by
this by the idea that he could ask to
meet privately with widows family
members of his victims partly because
many perpetrators so far those who had
apologized had made a show of their
apologies they had revered the idea of
apologizing in public but the [ __ ]
wanted to meet privately but secondly I
I was struck by the fact that the the
widows agreed to meet with him and and
curious to know what would transpire at
that meeting and as it turned out the
widows it was a difficult meeting a very
tense meeting and they were meeting the
person who was responsible for murdering
their loved ones for the first time
setting eyes on him for the first time
and they told me that most of the time
they cried at that meeting one of the
women said we were crying all the time
we did not know what to how to respond
to him but what was clear to us is that
he was sincere his apology was sincere
and she went on to say I want you to
tell the cook that our tears are not
just tears for our husbands but they are
tears for him as well I want to hold him
by the hand and to show him that it is
possible to change that there is a
future now I was just so amazed by these
words those words of forgiveness which
to me was really so much grace Express
for Eugene de Kock and I wanted to
understand I think both it the spiritual
and the psychological motives or tenants
of this process of forgiveness what
happens in that room what happens in an
encounter between a victim and the
perpetrator what is it that leads to
victims forgiving hand and and just
going deep into the stories of
forgiveness many other stories of
forgiveness it was clear to me that the
importance of that moment the importance
of setting eyes on somebody who had
murdered your loved ones if so has so
multiple roles for four victims one
which it is it real Elaine's the one
that you love it really gives you loved
one it reconstitutes them as a human
being when while they were murdered is a
non human being as a nonhuman they were
dehumanized by the perpetrator but when
the perpetrator archers words of apology
they are in a sense really humanizes in
your loved one they are really saying
yes this was a human being yes I killed
a human being I killed someone you loved
someone who is a wife a husband a father
all those qualities that were taken away
from the victim it is in a sense
reawakening the victim and recreating
if you may into the human being that
they wear and as one of the women said
it the truth that [ __ ] told them and his
apology allowed them to go back and to
be with their husbands and to release
them in order to begin the journey of
mourning so it's bringing them back in a
way in a symbolic sense and enabling the
victims to learn to begin the journey
towards towards healing for the victim
and this is not just for the perpetrator
it is on the one hand for the pair for
the victim it's not just for the for the
victim this reawakening of the humanity
of the of the dead loved one is also
important for for for the surviving
victim as well because it acknowledges
the pain an apology and a remorseful
apologies acknowledges the pain of the
victim it says it validates that penny
says yes I know that you're in pain and
in fact I am in pain for the harm that I
caused you for the perpetrator this is
his moment as well to reclaim himself of
humanity it in a sense it is a
readmission it invites him if he may to
join the community of moral human others
to rejoin society to rejoin me just this
individual but to rejoin society having
been symbolically cleansed a forgiving
victim allows the perpetrator to rejoin
the moral order of humanity that he had
denied when he committed his head of
atrocity and so it was that I was led to
speak to Eugene de Kock wanting to
understand whether he was deserving of
this forgiveness I wanted to understand
how much he's forgiven his apology was
was meaningful how serious it was
whether he he was just you know paying
lip service to the worst apology so I
was curious I had no business to be but
still just being with these women and
having a deep sense
of awareness about how important this
forgiveness was for them I wanted a
sense of understanding and understanding
how far de Kock's apology went and so I
went to see him and I'm going to read
from the book I'm going to read you the
passage from the section where I deal
with my first encounter with Eugene de
Kock i asked the [ __ ] to talk about the
meeting with pearl fargo and dorian go
to godís are the two widows his face
immediately fell and he became visibly
distressed I could hear the clutter of
his leg chains as he shuffled his feet
sitting directly across from me in the
small prison consulting room his heavy
glasses on the table that separated us
he started to speak there were tears in
his eyes in a breaking voice he said I
wish I could do much more than say I'm
sorry I wish there was a way of bringing
their bodies back alive I wish I could
say here are your husband's he said
stretching out his arms as if barring an
invisible body his hands trembling his
mouth quivering but unfortunately I have
to live with it relating to him in the
only way one does in such human
circumstances I touched his shaking hand
surprising myself but it was clenched
cold and rigid as if he were holding
back as if you were holding on to some
withering but still vital form of his
old self this made me recall for a
moment and to recast my spontaneous act
of reaching out as something
incompatible with the circumstances of
an encounter with a person who not so
long ago had used the same hands this
same voice to authorize and initiate
unspeakable acts of malice against
people very much like myself
now I pondered after this encounter with
de Kock the meaning of evil if the COG
who epitomized evil whom everyone
considered to be prime evil the evil of
apartheid to be the most representative
figure of apartheid evil how could he
break down how could he showed so much
emotion was this true was this an ant
what was it about and yet I felt that
when I reached out to him there was
nothing in Congress with my response of
empathy and compassion towards him I
felt that there was something rights in
my response to the [ __ ] but still this
was just the first interview and I had
in fact intended to see the [ __ ] to sit
with acog just for one session two hours
two and a half hours I never intended to
go back over and over again and to see
the [ __ ] over a period of three months
for a total of four to six hours which
is what I ended up doing but that first
interview raised very critical questions
in my mind about what it is hoe de Kock
is and what evil is if evil sometimes
presents in this way if evil sometimes
as the lurking behind it the quality of
humaneness what then do you understand
by evil and who is this man if he can
express pain in this way the pain of
remorse and so I went back to see the
[ __ ] connecting on a human level with a
monster is a profoundly frightening
prospect for ultimately it forces us to
confront the potential for evil within
ourselves these are the thoughts that
came to my mind when I was struggling
with this back and forth is seeing the
[ __ ] and dealing with my sense of
empathy for him comparison toward
enhanced forgiveness of people who have
left a gruesome trail in their wake in
fed brings innocent victims and wicked
men together to share at a single common
table of humanity and that prospect is
unpalatable Hannah Arendt writes that
radically evil adds transcend the realm
of human affairs and are therefore
neither punishable not forgivable the
radically evil unpunished ball because
no amount of punishment can balance what
they have done they are unforgivable
because no yardstick exists by which we
can measure what it means to forgive
them and there is no mental disposition
we can adopt toward them that would
correct the sense of injustice that
their actions have injected into our
world on the scale of horrible things
that can happen to people there are some
for which the language of apology and
forgiveness may be entirely
inappropriate to say however that some
evil deeds are simply unforgivable does
not capture the complexity and richness
of all the social context within which
gross evil is committed not all victims
were appeared on the truth commissions
hearings were willing or able to forgive
those who had so deeply violated their
integrity yet lessons from the TRC
proceedings approached with an open mind
and an heart can help us chart a path
along which forgiveness may occur as
well as the condition that make it
difficult or even morally in appropriate
to forgive on the one hand to dismiss
perpetrators simply as evildoers and
monsters shuts the door to the kind of
dialogue that leads to an enduring peace
daring on the other hand to look the
enemy in the eye and allow oneself to
read signs of pain and queues to
contrition or regret where one might
almost have preferred to continue seeing
only hatred is the one possibility we
have
for steering individuals and societies
towards replacing long-standing
stalemates out of a nation's past with
genuine engagement hope is where
transformation begins without it the
society cannot take its first steps
steps towards reconstructing it self
identity as a society of tolerance and
coexistence now this is what the Truth
and Reconciliation Commission gate by
bringing victims and perpetrators on the
same stage and encourage people to begin
to learn to talk to one another the
Commission really forced people to
consider the humanity of others the
humanity of people who were former
enemies and and this is what was
important about this breaking of cycles
of violence you do not vengeance is not
an option for societies that are
emerging out of conflict because people
get caught up in these cycles of
violence that so often repeat themselves
historically their cycles of violence
and hatred head to stop we put such a
high prime on vengeance revenge we often
believe that it's important to be
vengeful that revenge is such an
important emotion we always believe that
is often the right thing to do what we
forget is that sometimes victims want to
get rid of the bitterness and hatred
themselves most of the time victims
carry hatred and bitterness for years
and they're eager to get rid of it and
so the apologies that they receive from
perpetrators is really a gives them an
opportunity to to to to to to express
the sense of forgiveness and to reach
out to in a way to get rid of the of the
bitterness and hatred in fact
forgiveness is a way by which victims
get rid of their hatred that is this
this is why the we treasure these
restorative
a approach on the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission the restoring
of dignity of victims by giving them an
opportunity to look at another way an
alternative way to violence an
alternative way to vengeance and revenge
and and that is what is healing about
this process because it enables victims
to look towards their trauma in a
different way it gives them in your
language by which to talk about their
trauma one of the difficult things about
trauma is understanding it is finding
the language to explain and to
understand it we talk about traumatic
episodes as deeds that are a speakable
and indescribable the Commission gave it
a language gave it a language for
victims in order that they themselves
can articulate what happened and then
understand talk about themselves and
understand what happened to them and
this was the force that empowered them
to move on to take those steps towards
the road of healing there is no person
for me that exemplifies this approach
towards once trauma is RB sex as I did
my research for this book I came across
a book written by George Bizos with one
of the human rights lawyers in South
Africa very well known for his
participation in trials such as the
president former President Nelson
Mandela's trial and other a very
well-known a high-profile cases in South
Africa George Bizos wrote this book no
one to blame ? it looks he looks at all
of these crimes that were denied by
apartheid whose existence was denied by
the apartheid in this book he talks
about a conference that was held at
Columbia University with Albie was one
of the participants an RB was discussing
right then way back in nineteen 1889 the
importance of peace building in South
Africa the importance of a new approach
a new approach to an alternative to
vengeance in nineteen eighty
nine before Nelson Mandela was released
from prison IV was trying to impress
upon his comrades the importance of a
way that was certain to bring about
peace in South Africa and so I really
take my head off be an obvious as you
will see in the book is a very central
part for me in this tea in the
development of this work I want to end
in my discussion with you this evening
by reading you a section from the book
which is taken from one of my last
interviews with you gently [ __ ] it was
my pen ultimate interview with him and I
was preparing to come to this country to
read go back to the transcripts and to
begin writing the book and I was in the
prison the [ __ ] was no longer in Chains
he had graduated so to speak from the
status of dangerousness and so they give
it in the maximum security prison
prisoners were given various categories
and when he when I first saw him he was
in the very dangerous category very
dangerous prisoners category and so by
the time I was completing my interviews
with him he was in the not so dangerous
category of prisoners and so he was not
in Chains as usual my conversations with
de Kock had gone beyond the time I was
allowed to stay at the prison and true
gods came to the door to tell me my time
was up usually the [ __ ] was the first to
apologize and to get up to live with one
God is another waited for me to collect
my belongings but today as I put my tape
recorder pens and notebook in my bag I
noticed that the [ __ ] was still
lingering as if he had something to say
but did not quite know how to say it
although i continued to get ready to
leave i was stalling to see how he would
handle his uncertainty
decock came over and stood in front of
me arms folded and shoulders raised in a
stiff tense posture he first looked away
then looked back at me biting his lower
lip as if about to admit to something
terrible he had done a heavy silence
fell in hung in the room Pumbaa he began
I've been meaning to ask you this right
from our second interview have I ever
killed any of your friends or family the
words bounced around the large room like
an equal in a cave I actually turned and
looked around expecting perhaps to see
someone else in the room other than the
guards at the door I was sure that I had
heard the [ __ ] but had I just imagined
it standing there stand in conversation
with a broken man who had been an angel
of death I felt as if I were in the
midst of a collision of scattered
meanings within these prison walls that
had enclosed our conversations the [ __ ]
words hovered in the room I was
struggling to understand them before I
could take them in i looked at the [ __ ]
searching deep within his eyes reading
between the lines for signs of evil and
malice his eyes were filled with
suffering I felt nothing but pitting the
kind one feels when a friend is in pain
over an event that has deeply troubled
him I stared at his face again and for a
moment I thought I might touch him again
to offer him some respite from the
tortured emotions that seemed to be
causing through his brain and body but
how where could i touch him the
awkwardness of reaching out to someone
almost six feet tall
had killed many of my people and to do
it in front of the black guards who I
doubted had heard two [ __ ] question in
the large echoing room but was still
standing at the door holding it open and
watching what would they think what
would the [ __ ] think this black woman
reaching out to him with an embrace the
[ __ ] stood in front of me he sold us
bearing the weight of struggling with
the memory of his own evil I felt them
that even if the [ __ ] had killed my
loved ones I would never have been able
to tell him I would bug me I would have
had to spare him there was something in
his face that I hadn't seen before
something utterly despairing I finally
found my voice I said to him no you Jim
no one close to me the truth of course
is that the [ __ ] had killed my people
and people who had been fighting for my
struggle and so he had indeed people
skilled people close to me but it's this
sense of brokenness the sense of total
fragmentation of this man who on the one
hand is the evil decock but on the other
hand a man who is able to feel pain now
for me there is no greater moment in the
work of the truth and reconciliation
commission then to arouse the conscience
of the man who had committed the
terrible deeds under party there is no
greater hope for me than to see these
people really looking deeply into their
conscience and realizing that what they
did is now has no justification at all
what they did was evil
and being able to pick up the pieces or
beginning the struggle to pick up the
pieces to begin the road of cleansing
themselves in rejoining society the the
work of the Commission is them is the
most important far the most important
function of the Commission was to create
this possibility for these people to be
rehabilitated and to be reintegrated
into society and what better way to do
it than to give them if not forgiveness
or friendship or reconciliation it
leaves the idea that we can live and
coexist together even though we are
former enemies there is no higher call
to us all then the call for us to show
empathy for others even those whom we
might consider to be enemies thank you
very much to you all
there have been many great journeys in
recent years and some are accompanied by
fanfares and cheering crowds at the
beginning and end and others are quiet
intimate personal to me one of the great
ventures of the past few years was
Pumbaa keyboard America's Ella going to
meet the man the man
Eugene de Kock not only a proven killer
in a dedicated relentless organized
calculatedly murderous way have quite a
long period of time frequently with
extraordinary brutality not only an
actual individual with clearly
established culpability but Eugene de
Kock a representative an exemplar the
prime example of a history of violent
disposition of arrogant conquest of
utilization of superior physical core
force to enter the lives the land the
space the minds the visions the
imagination of others to insult them to
suppress them to subject them to
physical violence to belittle them the
man the Conqueror
the person in charge the state the
master the boss the epitome of those who
had come to Africa purporting to
represent a civilization and it trampled
on people and violated the alignat in
every possible way boom-lay went to meet
the man armed with integrity with the
tranquility that honest people have with
the tape recorder pen and paper with a
conscience with her knowledge of science
of human behavior of the unconscious and
with a sense of the Constitution
morality science integrity and a
constitution to meet violence force
power
to me this was a momentous encounter
that went well beyond just the two
individuals involved it was a journey of
our times a journey that engages our
inquiries and our imaginations and
happily unlike many momentous journeys a
journey beautifully recorded and told
with great delicacy and clarity
when I heard primula speaking at a
meeting of psychiatrists and
psychologists in Cape Town some years
back I hadn't known that you even
existed you were just a name on a piece
of paper as somebody who's going to be
in a particular workshop and yet the
words that came out gave me a sense of
extraordinary pride the pride of living
in a country where these kinds of
encounters could happen
we find the word evil used so freely and
so frequently in the world today and
normally the encounter with evil is set
up to simplify the relationship to
exclude the problematic we define what
is evil we define the people the groups
who are evil we define the conduct that
is evil and in so doing establish
ourselves as the good and the good
triumphs over evil and that triumphs
over evil because we've defined out all
the difficulties and problems of
contradictions because it is good and
evil is bad it triumphs over evil by
being more powerful than evil and being
more powerful is seen because the moral
dimension is already established and
taken for granted as being physically
more powerful and you exterminate evil
you beheaded you capture it you bomb it
you lock it up in darkness you exclude
it from the world because you are good
and evil is evil and evil doesn't belong
in the world of the good that's the one
approach
but the evil people or the people to
find us evo are simply obliterated
physically the evil as evil is not
engaged with the complexity the
relationship between people is not even
touched upon
perla went to meet the man the man who
was called by his colleagues and who
have glorified in the name of prime evil
I'm not suggesting that there was no
distinction between primula and Doc Ock
there was a huge difference between them
she a good person an honest person a
clear thinking person a kind person the
humane person he a person who had
manifested extreme cruelty extraordinary
in humanity in a calculated organized
dedicated scientific way so the point
isn't that we are all equally good and
all equally wicked but what she
established was the complexity of the
relationship between somebody a good
person standing for good values meeting
a person who had behaved with extreme
wickedness in defense of bad values and
what emerged from the encounter was a
willingness to discover and find in the
evil of that other person a human being
and the possibilities of good and the
recovery of good and an acknowledgment
that she as a person was not by
definition good
untainted perfect but also she could
have become evil or done wicked things
so it's not the destruction of evil
that's involved it's the transformation
of people who are evil even in this case
in conditions of restraint it wasn't in
that sense an equal meeting he was
trained at first he was locked up he was
disempowered he was deprived of the
possibilities of doing what he done
before perhaps even more important he
was stripped of the arrogance the moral
weapons that he'd had under apartheid
when he'd been congratulated and
rewarded when people flocked to the farm
to attend the barbecues to enjoy that
sense of triumph at exterminating what
they regarded as the evil enemy the
Freedom Fighters the resistance turning
the guerrillas around to become weapons
to fight other freedom fighters and that
world had been destroyed and collapsed
democracy had defeated it but not by
taking his life capital punishment
abolished in South Africa at the behest
of those who had suffered most from the
violence and the trauma from his ranks
as permanent said from her people from
our people the executed had been plucked
previously
it was a search for a new way of doing
things a new approach to humanizing a
country that had seen so much barbarity
and what was so striking and forceful
was that this search and eagerness to
reclaim the humanity even of the most
depraved came essentially from the
hearts of those who'd suffered the most
in the past it wasn't just the wonderful
Nelson Mandela coming out of prison
after 27 years with a relationship with
his gods with the former oppressors
talking negotiating it wasn't just
Oliver Tambo the other great leader of
the ANC who influenced me so directly
who implanted these ideas that we won't
have Nuremberg trials and executions in
South Africa who projected this idea
that the whites in South Africa had
never shown the humanity the largeness
of vision the generosity to live as
equals with their fellow countrymen and
women but we African people who suffered
so much trauma who know what it's like
to be disregarded as human beings we
have that humanity and we will extend it
to everybody in our country and that
will be our triumph not our defeat not
our weakness but our moral strength and
the victory of what we've been fighting
for and what we believe in and if George
Bizos thought I was being
generous at that stage I was simply
communicating a generosity that I picked
up from the leadership of the struggle
that I'd been in but it's not just these
prominent outstanding leaders it's not
just the Desmond Tutu's it's not just
the Pumas and already the list is
beginning to extend there's two African
women widows probably from fairly
impoverished backgrounds not trained in
psychiatry not deep informal philosophy
but with a generosity that was part
parcel of the culture something they
imbibed with their mothers milk and that
they passed on with their milk to their
children showing an astonishing
generosity and humanity and something
that when it counters all over the
country waiting to come out waiting for
a chance to articulate itself the term
is often used in South Africa lubuntu to
represent something in African culture
and society it's a way of looking at the
world I am a human being because you are
a human being I cannot separate my
humanity from acknowledging your
humanity no single human being is
completely beyond the pale we all bear
responsibility for all
the fellow citizens of this world and if
they've committed terrible evil like
Eugene de Kock did we must try and
explore why and reestablish connections
with people like that I say this because
there's so much cynicism in the world
there's such a strong sense that
forgiveness is a kind of weakness that a
generosity of that kind is idealistic
its inane it's self-defeating we got a
country because of that we ended a war
because of that we are moving forward
with difficulty with problems setbacks
but essentially because of that so this
particular journey this extraordinary
journey boom-lay with a tape recorder a
conscience of science and a constitution
going to meet the man of violence that
is the story of South Africa I'm going
to meet him not to humiliate him to
castrate him to destroy what shreds of
dignity has left but to try and reclaim
and discover something of a human being
in that terrible killer that is the
story of our country it's a beautifully
told story with a clarity that you can
only get from someone whose vision is
pellucid and clear his sense of science
and history and philosophy
is clear who's willing to interrogate
herself in her own actions and who has
the confidence of a culture of a society
will be not afraid to look truth in the
face it's a beautiful book boom now I'd
like you to give it to me I want to hold
it up for everybody to see it's not
you're doing this I'm doing the promo
it's called a human being died that
night a South African story of
forgiveness it's just coming out now and
if you want to read a book with all the
complexity of clear morality of a book
that's willing to accept that paradox
and strangeness and unresolved questions
or part and parcel of life of a book
that says idealism matters that hope is
important that each one of us can find
something in ourselves and in our labor
and in our enemies it makes human
existence worthwhile read this book and
if you like good plain straightforward
English that carries a memento story
read this book read this book read this
book read this book
you can actually buy the book in the
back but before that we would like to
give a chance for questions because we
can't move the mics because of the
c-span cameras and such I would ask you
to come forward there's bikes on either
side here in the aisles and that will
that means that everybody can hear your
question and that will make it easier
not only for our guests who are going to
respond to your question but also for
everybody else in the audience so I
would ask anybody with questions to come
forward if you want to buy a book it can
go backward
thank you very much for Jean here my
question is since this is work so well
for South Africa why do you think
there's so much reluctance form the
United States to try this with Iraq or
Israel to try it with the Palestinians
thank you very much I will try and my
response rail is that while the truth
commission would in South Africa it was
a unique process and did indeed break
the cycles of violence in South Africa
it is not duplicate necessarily
duplicable in other parts of the world
where there is conflict but I think that
their lessons their themes within the
commission that can be learned and used
in other in other conference two of
those acknowledgments acknowledgement of
past wrongs that the one of the
important ways of understanding conflict
is to travel the road of the past we
often think that the past is past and
that's why it should belong and yet when
people have suffered trauma in the past
there's those traumatic experiences are
very much present people don't forget
what happened even if it's not talked
about they don't forget that these
things happened so it is important to
remember that in order to move forward
to build a society 222222 really take
that risk and move with former enemies
in and to transform society it is
important to begin to look back in order
to move forward the idea and secondly
what the Commission has taught us is
that the logic of revenge is implacable
because what it does it just places
violence with violence hate with hate it
was Martin Luther King jr. whose
birthday was being celebrated the other
day who said in one of his speeches I
think it was that the dexter avenue
baptist church in montgomery AL alabama
that you you cannot replace hate with
hate hate with hate simply rebuilds
violence and someone who said someone
somewhere must break the site that the
cycle of hatred and evil and that that
is something that this country knows
about in the civil rights movement as
led by martin luther king jr. and so
many people in fact who have followed
the story followed the story of south
africa realize that the the success of
south africa has been around these two
notions that first acknowledgement is
important you acknowledge wrong past
wrongs and past hurts and secondly that
in order to transform society and to
transform even the evildoers it is
important to look them in the eye to
invite them to join the Society of moral
others and you do that by creating these
these forums that will enable them to
dig deep into their conscience force
them as it way to look truth in the eye
and to speak it thank you
thank you for coming tonight and helping
us to sort of human eyes ourselves a
little bit even than a little traumas we
face we're lucky we haven't faced
anything like you did in your country
myself I haven't there are other
struggles that are here and have been
here I have two questions they're
related one is can you quantify for us
in any sense that the people the numbers
of people who may have been reconciled
through this process so that we get an
idea of a balance of those who did and
did not and secondly I had heard of
reports and read of things that talked
about a punishment for coming for those
who did not reconcile who did not come
to grips with the the grievous wrongs
that they committed and and people were
arguing about that should not be that
was not the purpose what has happened
after the fact with those people who
have not come forward and the I will
respond to your second question first of
all the the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission had provision for the
prosecution of people who did not come
forward to testify people perpetrators
who refused to come to the Commission
they were liable to prosecution
including those who were refused amnesty
so it was really a a balance between
restorative justice and retributive
justice by allowing the courts to pursue
those people who did not come forward to
the Commission there were very clear
provisions for that now that has not
quite happened in that way I think in
part because of the just the complexity
of that process and because it in quite
requires so much preparation by way of
court proceedings oddly my purse be a
better person to respond to that in
terms of why people have not been
pursued why
the prosecution's have not been pursued
although there were provisions within
the truth Commission's numbers there
were a total of more than actually
22,000 victims who came to testify
before the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission their statements the the
record and they were found to be victims
of gross violations of human rights
about 7,000 perpetrators applied for
amnesty and very small percentage of
those were granted amnesty many of the
7,000 in fact fell outside of the
Mandate of the curve of the Commission
that is to say they are cases were not
within the Mandate of the truth
commission they were not they were found
not to be politically motivated so
perhaps about fourteen percent of the
total 7,000 who initially applied for
amnesty were actually granted amnesty by
the Commission in terms of who what the
numbers I in terms of people were
reconciled I think that question while
the question is important but in the
larger scale of the entire process of
the truth commission it does not become
that relevant because the experience of
what happened on the stage of the
commission was a public process the way
it was televised on a daily basis there
was there were live broadcast there was
live broadcast of the hearings on a
daily basis on national radio which is
like national public radio in this
country so the vicarious experience by
the Society of the stories that happen
in the truth commission stage are really
what was important to generate this
momentum within society the momentum
that enabled people to to to consider
the the historical moment in our history
and to join hands in moving towards
rebuilding Society or lives in
identifying with the process of
rebuilding Society so it was not so much
how many people
a forgiving and how many perpetrators
apologize because if you do that then we
miss out on the the effects of the
process of the truth commission the
effect of those great stories of
forgiveness that happened on the
transformative power not just at an
individual level but at the whole
society eye level many people in South
Africa or rather some people in South
Africa were very skeptical you know they
did not believe this process was going
to do any good but by the time the work
of the Commission was completed there
were people who were embracing the new
process the new South Africa the idea of
rebuilding was something that was in
everybody's mind and and and and so
really the question of numbers is not as
critical as what the effect of this
process was in the nation and that
effect was very powerful in just making
people identify with this new society
that was was it evolving right before
our eyes hi I'm so happy that you came
tonight don't underestimate how much
your experience in South Africa affect
affected all of us I listened to the
hearings the proceedings that were going
on years ago when they were on the radio
and it helped me focus and believe that
humanity we can retain our humanity and
I think it affected I don't know if we
could count how many people had affected
everywhere I had a question for both of
you it's more practical question I'm
very concerned with how we retain our
humanity and possibly you might have
gotten from this man to call his d [ __ ]
to [ __ ] his an understanding of how he
lost his humanity and the lessons for us
all how people with fair skin who were
born into privilege can help others who
are in that position find their humanity
and stay with it instead of going down
the other Road of evil that is in all of
us the humanity and evil together could
you both please briefly
in the 1960s late 1960s right through
the 70s and the 1980s the refrain within
apartheid circles was that there is a
threat out there and the threat is a
terrorist threat and those were defined
as terrorists where people who were
opposing the policies of the apartheid
government and so there was this
mentality over the years that was
instilled within society in the
government stepped up stepped up its
security forces it increased it
increased its covert operations it put
passed laws that would imprison
anti-apartheid activists for long
periods of time without being charged
there was the 90-day law that allowed
the apartheid government to continue
imprisoning people and torturing them in
prison the language changed over the
years in South Africa the language was
the language of fear and so the society
particularly the majority of white
people who did not see apartheid for
what it is who continues to vote for the
apartheid government in feds came to
vote in numbers over the years by 19 by
the 1980s there were more white people
who voted for apartheid it more than
they were in the 1960s because the
message of fear was succeeding in South
Africa and so slowly and slowly people
not being able to see by not being able
to see the gradual slipping into this
abyss of evil really the abuse of just
this support of a system that was
oppressing a group of people simply
because they were black they
and murdering anyone who opposed who
opposed it and in having many people
ostracized white people oppose the
government in those days where ostracize
completed by the society in fact some
people were even ostracized by their
varied by their own families and so this
cart off yay you know the army building
the army conscripting young white men to
join the army and sending them up to
find a party's war in the townships in
the border to stop the liberation forces
in neighboring states all of those
things are the slow progressions that
the part this is the part that people
walk towards becoming evil you don't see
it is the small steps you know you get
on the slope you'd step on that on the
pebble you are gone and if you don't
recognize it you are indeed gone and so
the challenge really is how do you
recognize these small steps and how do
we make sure that we don't fall into
that trap the many leaders that I can
count who who are just symbols of
speaking out symbols of doing the right
thing symbol of very strong sense of
moral conscience who spoke to speak out
and spoke out against evil we're able to
speak out against evil who perhaps lead
the way and now we are challenged by
processes such as what happened in South
Africa not only to see how it is
possible for ordinary human being to
become bystanders in silent while even
evil is emerging and evolving in before
eyes but we also able how it is possible
for for us who are outsiders looking
observing these events how it is
possible for us to even get to that
point of silence in them of always
almost completely with this
complicity with these kinds of behaviors
and I that is really my response to your
question about this you know these these
challenges that we face these are very
big moral dilemmas that we have I mean
to what extent do you speak out people
the ordinary person is afraid one can
have to recognize that the ordinary
person in the street is afraid but what
we find is that you think of the only
one you are afraid because you think of
the only one you're going to be
ostracized and yet there's so many
others are they want an opportunity to
speak out but don't have it because they
don't know that they will be support for
it so fear is another very dangerous
quality that just destabilizes us and
allows evil to happen in our societies
can I just say something in relation to
an earlier question on reconciliation to
my mind the most painful thing for the
families and the actual victims was not
the process itself but the going home
afterwards the people who'd belonged to
families that were poor that were living
in impoverished areas under part right
now with enormous moral changes trained
as constitutional changes go home after
the proceedings to impoverish
surroundings and those who cause such
terrible pain to them sometimes after
crying at the tribunal expressing
emotion being stuff in their bodies all
the different ways they drive home in
cause to beautiful homes to the extent
that our society still remains
relatively unreconstructed the process
of reconciliation is incomplete but what
the truth commission did was at least at
laid out the truth at least at the moral
level it enabled us to start living in a
single moral universe where the basic
values and the norms and standards would
be the same for everybody if you don't
have that you can add any amount of
material change and advance you still
have that sense of inherited a legacy of
bitterness that's unresolved so we dealt
with the hardest part I often say in
South Africa we great at miracles and
doing the impossible we're not so good
at the ordinary so now we have to
concentrate on the ordinary and its
houses and jobs and education and health
and dealing with hiv/aids and things of
that kind
it's unfair to load onto the truth
commission the whole historical burden
of transforming our society it's fairer
to give it a critical role in terms of
establishing a moral climate and
humanizing relationships and opening the
way for the other kinds of advanced in
terms of what do we do to avoid evil the
Commission did report on that one of its
terms of reference was how did it come
about where were where was the press
when these things were happening telling
stories filled with disinformation where
was business making profits providing
the weapons used by the state to repress
the others where was the church
frequently the chaplains praising and
blessing the killers and those
responsible for as they put a defending
our Christian civilization against evil
and one of the points that comes out
evil never speaks in the name of evil
evil doesn't say we are evil and this
you're a rocker or a biker or some lead
deliberately trying to provoke evil says
we are good we are defending our country
we are defending our women [ __ ] we are
defending our civilization you are
defending the world so one has to go
behind the pretensions and claims of
those in power waiver the judges my
colleagues
how could these things happen if you had
a judiciary that was vigilant that
defended basic rights they didn't simply
say what the state does provided it has
some imprimatur of law behind it is okay
where were the judges that questions
been asked and we answered it maybe not
as robustly indirectly as we should have
done but if we prepared a document
saying the judiciary failed we supported
the executive even where we had a scope
for defending civil liberties the judges
didn't do so as vigilantly as they could
have done we enforced the apartheid laws
the judiciary was part and parcel of
that whole process of oppression maybe
it's a professional inclination of mine
now but I think one of the criteria one
can use for measuring where the evil is
given scope to triumph is the rule of
law is the defense of civil liberties is
the undermining of the values of the
society that you are trying to defend in
advance as incorporated in due process
of law and proper procedures and basic
rights for everybody's that nobody is
such an enemy of the state such a total
outlaw that he or she is beyond the
reach of law where that happens and that
happened in our country and that was the
basis for the terrible violence I'm not
just speaking about the violence of
apartheid itself but the violence used
to defend apartheid clandestine secret
denied was dependent upon
the total distraction of the rule of law
the processes of protecting people
through the courts from this kind of
violence and so one of the
recommendations of the Commission was
the necessity to educate the general
public in a culture of respect for human
rights through the schools the public
media and to strengthen the judiciary
the legal institutions public defenders
to make constitutionalism a living
reality for everybody in our society and
we've made a lot of progress in that
regard and if we look around the world
we find other countries that have
contributed enormously to the idea of
protection of human rights wavering and
creating Limbo's and spaces in which the
protection of rights owner doesn't seem
to matter then one's very concerned
about whether the fight against evil
doesn't spawn new evils of its own
are a lot of time is over however puma
is here to sell books and she's going to
go to the back and she'll even sign it I
think if you're good so we have time
thank you very much everybody editorial
poum laga bodo madikizela is currently
an associate professor of psychology at
the University of Cape Town a human
being died that night is published by
houghton mifflin on the web at houghton
mifflin ebooks.com